Bachelorette contestant Derrick past  defends his tears oh my god Derrick was  sent home literally crying with a full  musical number Monday night  and he is hilariously addressing the  tears on Twitter saying quote when a man  cries in Argentina a unicorn is born but  then not so much hilariously has a bit  aggressively Derek fired back at  Bachelorette superfan Jenny McCarthy  jenny tweeted is it wrong that I have a  maniacal laugh while watching Derek cry  and Derek snapped back this is as  acceptable as your fight against  vaccines hashtag science  yikes well some people are actually  saying they want Derek as the next  Bachelor  what do you think let me know on twitter  i'm at lauren zima